et puis selon certaines publications
internationales les risques de cancer et
notamment de leucémies sont plus
important lorsqu'on habite à proximité
d'une centrale nucléaire
pour autant les études menées jusqu'à ce
jour sont contradictoires
nathalie sa peña et virginie travers
c'est une question qui taraude tous les
riverains des sites nucléaires et que
relance les incidents du tricastin vivre
à proximité d'une centrale est ce
dangereux pour la santé
une interrogation que les militants
antinucléaires se pose depuis toujours
le problème même avec des centrales
jeunes c'est que il ya des rejets de gaz
radioactif et d'effluents radioactifs
même en fonctionnement normal
donc le problème c'est que les
populations sont contactés ces effluents
la radioactivité provoque des leucémies
les cancers de la thyroïde ou du sein en
allemagne une étude publiée cet hiver
est venu alimenter les inquiétudes
selon cette étude il y a deux fois plus
de leucémie chez les enfants qui vivent
au pied des centrales allemandes
le plus surprenant c'est que le risque
pour les enfants de tomber malade de la
leucémie est d'autant plus élevé que le
réacteur est proche chaude une
conclusion qui n'est pas corroborée par
les experts français eux ont analysé 200
études réalisées en europe
tout converge il n'y a pas
d'augmentation de la fréquence des
décennies chez les 0 24 ans à proximité
des sites nucléaires du point de vue
scientifique les résultats allemands
actuellement sont tout à fait isolé
rapport à l'ensemble des connaissances
scientifiques isolés mais des
incertitudes subsistent car il n'y a
aucun suivi sanitaire spécifique des
riverains des sites nucléaires
quant aux 73 mille habitants de la zone
du tricastin
ils seront bientôt s'ils ont plus de
cancers que la population générale
une étude sera lancée en octobre
prochain